joining us now senior adviser to Donald
J Trump for president 2020 Laura Trump
is with us I know you're used to the
attacks more importantly free health
care free housing
oh and Lizabeth Warren wants free
daycare we're gonna have guaranteed
healthy food guaranteed pretty vacations
Medical Leave all that even if you're
unwilling to work yeah well it's it's
also crazy Shawn and what I think people
need to realize when we're talking about
socialism it is it essentially the
government taking over as you're
explaining almost every aspect of your
life and in America that is not right
that is not who we are as a country
that's not what our country was founded
on these things are becoming incredibly
mainstream within the Democrat Party and
it's gonna be very hard for people to
distance themselves from these come to
2020 election I tend to think let them
keep digging themselves in a hole
because the the average American in this
country I think sees how crazy these
ideas are and how quickly this would
bankrupt our country and lead us down a
path much like Venezuela is right now
we're sean they're eating dog and cat
food to survive you see that they don't
even have beds in their hospitals
they're in deplorable conditions people
are starving to death that is not
something that we want to see happen in
the United States of America people have
to take socialism and anyone's running
on a socialist platform incredibly
symbolic how are they gonna convince
Americans that we're going to eliminate
all fossil fuels the cars we love to
drive the lifeblood of our economy every
American is gonna have to retrofit and
remodel their home Oh
cows are going away no airplanes and
we're going to what have sailboats to
Europe and high-speed trains to
Australia New Zealand it makes
absolutely no sense and when you
actually get get down to and start to
ask questions like this I think often
times they really can't answer you they
say well we'll find the money for it
well who's paying for it Sean the
reality is they want to tax seventy to
ninety percent taxes on the American
citizens think about that what that
would mean for everyone
across this country it is so crazy it's
never gonna happen to the country I
think what's happening New York New
Jersey Connecticut Illinois California
California lost a million people they
left the state 13,000 businesses left
the state in less than ten years they're
all losing they're all losing people in
their states because they're leaving
there's a high taxes and burdensome
regulation if they do it nationwide
what do you think those people that have
money are going to do they're gonna move
their money and yourselves you got that
right everybody in New York is moving to
Florida and guess what if they try to do
it in this country people are moving out
of the country it is going to spell
disaster
absolutely yeah pretty scary all right
Laura Trump great to see you congrats on
the baby I hear babies running around
jumping on the sofa he's into everything
I know the first walking stages step
step scary all right good to see you